okay should be ready to go now okay okay
apologies everybody I can't get my my
video camera working so I'm gonna have
to just work with the with a microphone
so you'll be able to hear me and I can
certainly see everybody who's taking
parcel good afternoon and welcome to
this planning meeting my name is
Lawrence Walsh and I'm the chair of this
meeting councillor Agee with Aiden
Williams is the vice chair in attendance
we have senior planning officers
together with officers from regal
highways democratic services and members
of council who make up this planning
committee please be aware that this
meeting will be recorded for live and
for subsequent broadcast on the
council's YouTube channel the whole of
the meeting will be recorded except
where they are come there are
confidential items or exempt items this
activity promotes democratic engagement
in accordance with section 100 a permit
Act in 1972 members are asked to mute
their microphone to minimize background
noise when they are not speaking if you
wish to speak to an item please use a
chat facility to notify myself and then
wait till I invite you to speak before
making your comments sorry before making
your comments please state your name so
go to the first item on the agenda and
that's attendances and I've got
apologies from councillor Stennett and
councillor Thomas is going to be
substituting for comes with spinner are
you with us
councillor Thomas councillor Thomas can
you hear me
[Music]
no it comes what Thomas here can anybody
advise me yes yes you can hear me Simon
yes thank you that's fine and we've not
heard from Council and Minnis and advice
she's a key worker and she's very busy
but I'm not advised that she's not
coming or that she is coming she made
sure not later
she's very welcome to attend that if and
when she can arrive and I took number
two his declarations of interest members
to give notice of any prejudice personal
or producer interest and the nature of
that interest relating to an item on the
agenda in accordance with the adopted
code of conduct
so rather than highlight in any interest
you've got when they arrive on the
agenda were asking people to declare
them here and now I'd some - anybody got
any interest to declare no that's far
right so number three is the minutes and
if so determined to approve was a
correct record the minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of May 2020
with anybody like to move those minutes
as a true and correct record happy to
move the minutes Joe Thank You
councillor Williams is that a second did
anyone like second do I put a second
chair second camp Thank You councillor
Hartley and item number four is
questions from members of the public
onions I understand that no questions
have been received today item number
five is the additional information
report I hope you've all like copies to
that and office dissent match who was
this afternoon and before we go to item
number six a reminder to members of the
planning committee that as well as our
local knowledge we look to the
background papers listed at the
beginning of agenda item six as a basis
for our decision-making deceiving by
this afternoon I should say so I gender
item sticks at applications to develop
and the first occasion we're going to
discuss is instant Tennis Club
and that is on page one and we have mr.
Butterfield with us he's going to speak
against this application
mr. bottle just get yourself ready and
we're gonna have an introduction from
mr. Pearson is it person speak to this
Thank You chairman um I'm just gonna try
and share my screen before I read out
the introduction so that you can
hopefully see what I'm talking about and
put it in context if you just bear with
me that should have come up on your
screens and I consider you confirm that
they can see that's good thank you okay
so this application relates to three
existing astroturf tennis courts at
constant
cricket and Lawn Tennis Club which is
situated off more side road in Holmstrom
the site is sandwiched between Ohm's
turn Grammar School to the east and out
when he caught a three-story apartment
block to the west
Planning Commission sought for
installation of twelve seven meter high
flood lighting columns on the three
existing astroturf colleges this drawing
isn't as clear as it might be but you
should be able to see how when he caught
to the left there where my cursor is and
then the courts across here a total of
fourteen luminaires would be fitted to
the columns its proposed that the foot
lighting could be in use up to 10 p.m.
on any day of the year the MPP F and
cause strategy policy of supportive of
proposals to improve outdoor sports the
opportunities for sport and physical
activity that may offer the club also
expect fertilizing would help greatly
with membership subscriptions that
therefore the viability of the club
however these community benefits must be
balanced against the impacts on amenity
particularly that of residence within
close to the site
there's an illustration on screen there
of of how the light will is likely to
spill from from the court now the
council's pollution team have advised
that they're unable to support the
application because of the impact of the
flood lighting on the amenity of
residents living in the adjacent
properties at Albany Court
you can see the relationship of the
courts to our when he caught on on your
screen now pollution licensing officers
are concerned that a statutory nuisance
may occur now that's a level of harm
that goes beyond that of harm to amenity
the Tessa we would normally apply in
consideration of a planning application
moreover the applicants have failed to
demonstrate at this time would not arise
through the submission of an
appropriately detailed technical report
it's considered that the proposal would
cause undue harm from the bright
illumination an intrusion of light and
glare the applicants have also failed to
demonstrate that will be no and to harm
amenity resulting from noise and
disturbance through the extended hours
of play that the floodlights would
facilitate so whilst weight should be
given to the benefits to well-being
through physical activity that the
improved sporting facilities would bring
the concern about the impacts on the
amenity of residents at Albany Court is
such that the application is recommended
for refusal Thank You chairman I could I
can leave that image up if you like or I
can take it down I'm not sure what
members want to do
you
Gemma can you hear me
yeah can you hear me David I can yes I
was just saying you'll be - leave the
image on the screen and would you let me
- thank you down so we can see speakers
thank you take it down take it down yeah
yeah please okay do we have mr.
Butterfield with us mr. Butterfield
hello can you hear me
yes mr. Butterfield we can hear you yes
sorry I should say it's Butterfield
Groves all right sorry mr. Butterfield
groves you're very welcome thank you you
have three minutes mr. Butterfield
groves thank you thank you I'm in
support of the application and I think
you made it I think you said I was
speaking against the application earlier
so just to be clear I'm also good if I
start my three minutes now that would be
very helpful this is a crucial time for
the club ten years ago we had more
courts than members no teams and no
junior activities the club was very near
folding since then an army of volunteers
has created a growing membership but
we're still in a perilous financial
position our regeneration plan has been
prepared in association with the Lawn
Tennis Association traffic council
sports and leisure team and local
schools and is funded by many bodies
including traffic housing and trust the
officer report makes the club sound more
financially stable than it actually is
we live from hand to mouth tennis is the
only sport that can make the club a
year-round facility the coronavirus also
means the clubhouse will be closed for
the foreseeable future and so the club
now runs on membership fees and
volunteering alone we need more members
and we need a year-round offer we assure
you that the club has at every turns
thought to minimize the impact of our
proposals we also urge you to take
account of the huge local support
including at least two counselors
traffic council's own sports and leisure
team the Lawn Tennis Association for
local schools and 59 letters of
community risk for support let's be
clear the community wants these
facilities we regret that there
still some objections but have worked
with residents many objections have been
withdrawn many residents are now
planning to become more involved in a
club and we truly welcome this we could
not have done any more furthermore the
grounds for refusal a week and would
struggle it to peel the lights will only
be used in the hours of darkness when
the residents curtains and windows are
closed furthermore they do not affect a
single bedroom noise is a complete red
herring as we already play until after
10 o'clock during the summer and we have
never had a single complaint there are
also many established planning
precedents including the very nearby
flicks tin girls schools much bigger
floodlit football facility which is
right next to another housing estate the
Lawn Tennis Association studies predict
that membership will grow by 50% with
flood lighting this is a real
opportunity that must be grasped more
members could create jobs for full-time
coaches and support the three full-time
and five part-time jobs already at the
club
we can't retained coaches who can only
work half the year tennis for all is our
motto and we truly deliver on this our
coaching subsidizes disadvantaged
children providing free equipment and
lessons we're a partner in the council's
parks tennis initiative and will host
free community sessions in the winter
under these floodlights our members age
from 5 to 82 and we also host
Manchester's only LGBTQ tennis club we
are truly a community club should the
club fold we'll be applying for housing
on the site and this would bring its own
objections to conclude our case is clear
we have worked with the council at each
stage and now need your support in
planning terms we don't please don't
stand in the way of the rebirth of this
important community asset we urge you to
grant consent today thank you thank you
mr. Butterfield girls
there's no speakers in favor of the
application so I'll go to the committee
I was speaking in favor of the
application so who's that
mr. Butterfield groves oh you were
speaking favorite so mr. Butterfield
across there's nobody speaking against
the application and so I'm gonna go to
the committee
many members like to begin the debate
comes would your own before mere feet if
he wants to go first but I think he's
relaxed about that you go first on many
respects and a good good scheme in terms
of sport community and access but I
think the report does have some
appreciable worries and it will create a
disturbance to the adjacent flats openly
Court is for the over fifty five and
residents of it are of an age where they
do need peace and quiet and I think if
you look at the report and the writing
and the Environmental Protection Team
can't support it and they're writing
that it's a very low hedge so when
offered occurs screening and I'm point
seventeen the application proposes to
use the courts to 10:00 p.m.
on any day potentially for out of the
year and I think point nineteen goes on
to say the residents will be able to see
at close quarters that you know large
brightly illuminated area so I think
though this is a good application I
think it needs to do more to address the
light issues in terms of screening and
the lights themselves but also has to
have a better plan on when the court
should be used and when that light
shouldn't be maybe there needs to be you
know some some nights where tennis isn't
being played in until ten o'clock so
yeah for me I'd I'm inclined to agree
with the officer recommendation but I'd
also like to hear others speak on the
matter too before making up my mind so
uh thank you Joe Thank You counselors
you're on counsel approach obviously
this is in my ward and I know the area
very well and I know the Tennis Club
very well I mean they've done some
fantastic work
to increase take-up of Tennyson in the
area and they'd be very successful so
far obviously very recharging situation
they're in and they do they do niche
trying to expand saying that I am really
torn with this application because I
think some of the concerns and residents
about the lighting it's justified and
it's one of these these balancing acts I
think we need to really really consider
in detail you know the the community
benefit against the potential harm to
the residents there's some things about
the objections I don't agree with I
think that the issue about parking is
not relevant really this large amount of
potential parking the sports club nearby
and most evenings at the the grammar
school as well and I'm more sad Road
itself so I don't think with the numbers
of people are going to be coming to the
change club if this was granted it would
have any significant impact on parking
at all and I'm the noise issue I
actually in normal times I go past
though because I play by Benson at the
the grammar school once a week and the
noise levels are not particularly high
you know you just have you know the
noise of tennis balls and occasional
shouts from people so I think that's
been over exaggerated really I don't
think noise levels are going to be
significant to disturb the residents of
a Blee culture and principally talking
about the one area where I think you
know there are genuine issues is in the
lighting there's not a great deal of
screening there are some bushes there
and what the the amount of screening is
is going to be quite quite limited so I
think there's going to be some some
impact on residents I think they're in
reality most of the activity on the
cause
is going to be through the summer months
I think yeah in the sort of winter
evenings when it's the weather's bad I
think there's not going to be I not have
that the club has some plans to do
increasing but I think in reality you're
not we're playing tennis in their
winters that we have in this country
significant way so it's a real difficult
one but I think on balance I'm going to
go against the offers as recommendations
and I switch to be approved I think the
benefits are fantastic for the people in
the community and the limited effect an
amenity in my mind not gonna be enough
for us to reject this application so
it's a difficult one I have to say but
that's my conclusions in the end Thank
You chair Thank You councillor Proctor
and council William did like to speak
comfortable use Thank You chair and this
is an application that I'd really like
to be able to support this evening I
think when you read through the
representations it's really clear that
it's a popular community facility my
sole concern relating to the application
and I agree with mr. Butterfield groves
that the question of noise nuisance is a
red herring my sole concern relates to
the flood lighting and their use
potentially up until 10 p.m. every
evening and that the council's
regulatory services director are saying
that in their opinion it would cause a
statutory nuisance it's a matter of huge
concern and I think it just needs to be
emphasized the word permission to be
granted for these flood lights to be
erected a subsequent complaint be
received
then the council's regulatory services
Directorate would have to investigate
that and may very well then have to take
enforcement proceedings against the club
with the statutory powers that granted
to them by law so for that reason alone
I can't support the application this
evening I really hope that the
that can can find a way to work again on
the proposal with the local authority
and to find an alternative way to extend
the use of the club in the facilities so
that's all that I can encourage really
can and with that I will be moving that
we vote in line with office a
recommendation and we fused the
application tonight thank you Joe
Thank You councillor Williams Council at
Thomas thank you Joe
again liked it like most people it is
basically the light pollution that will
occur to residents how many got a note
from the the drawing that came up at the
beginning that there are lights that are
facing directly up the court I think
houses from the center of the courts
there is a seemingly good way out of
this if the lights on each individual
court is controlled separately because
as the evenings draw in and get later
the the court nearest to almani could
perhaps be and D eliminated and the
other two calls which would obviously
reduce the illumination on - how many
call be used only that is a potential
way around this because obviously again
it is a facility as being the area and
used greatly for a long time and it
would be beneficial to allow it to grow
but not the expense of residents Thank
You councillor thomas council wind
Stanley Thank You chair like the
previous speakers I came into the
committee meeting that tonight starting
conflicted on this because it is a great
idea it's a great opportunity but the
many of the objections don't really
stand up to scrutiny the parking and the
noise and the rest of everyone there any
sudden scrutiny is the and the light
pollution for the reasons which counsel
in Williams said however one of the
previous speak second remember who's
which one this was said something which
I'm with me is the reality will be
in the winter which is when this is the
only real town has had the effect
because the tennis has already played
with the ten o'clock in the summer at
the club given them given me the weather
we've had the floodlights will probably
not get used so for that reason on a on
a way in the planning balance I will be
voting to go against the officers
recommendation and to support the
apprehension Thank You chair Thank You
councillor wind Stanley and counselor
dr. Barkley thank you letting me speak
and I really do feel sympathetic to the
applicants on this application it's a
really good application it's great to
get the community involved in tennis
it's so good for everybody's health and
obviously it's even exciting residents
who live in the flats but very sadly if
we are about to put a statutory nuisance
on to residents which I feel personally
I just cannot support the application
for that and unfortunately it is a
really common issue I remember an
applications coming before committee in
the past where it's been schools looking
to pop floodlights up and it is really
really difficult cuz these things are
very often surrounded by residents and
often in flats and often as severely
impacted and we do really have to
protect our residents but I just wanted
to say and that I hope the applicant and
if there if it isn't severe prove today
and if the applicant can go back and
think about the things that other
schools and sports because I've done to
try and make this kind of scheme work so
I'm thinking of things like retractable
lighting and obviously thinking about
schemes for life seeing as has already
been suggested so for sure I can't can't
approve the scheme that's in front of us
today and that's what we've got to
consider but I hope that it should not
be approved you know that'll go away
keep working hard for the community
because we'd really love to see a scheme
that can work for everybody that's
involved residents and obviously
participants thank you chair
okay Thank You counsel dr. Barkley and
councillor Jerome did you want a second
counselor Williams proposal that we
grump this okay are there any proposals
for us to reject it she'll just take one
bolt and see how that goes everybody
help you do that
so each had to clarify I propose that we
refuse to go the money permission
application yes oh yes yeah
recommendation to refuse it counselor
drama seconded that does anyone want to
move that we grunts it okay so we'll
just take that that that vault there
it's been moved and seconded that we
refuse this application along with
officers recommendation so I'll need to
go through all your names individually
and apologies for the time-consuming
okay counselor dr. Barkley Thank You
chair I am in favor of refusal you
counselor Carrie refused all pleas
champion Thank You counsel accordingly
council accordingly sorry I was a bit
slow there getting the microphone off
and reject the officers recommendation
and support or allow Thank You counselor
heartily I refused the application so
agree with officer recommendation thank
you
comes with your own foundation to refuse
counselor Morgan agree with officer
recommendations charity reviews thank
you come to the proctor I'm obviously
then approve the application right Thank
You counselor Rigby Thank You counselor
Williams
teacher Support Officer recommendation
to refuse you come to the wind
that's who go get out with Beijing and
class chair okay I'll just count those
numbers I think it's a refusal I've got
six or a few years olds three grams that
applications been refused and thank you
very few contributions therefore the
application has been refused
I'm Sergeant custom oh sorry
because the Thomas sorry apologies for
that councillor Thomas I told you I to
vote I agree with the recommendation of
the awesome right so that's seven seven
volts to three refusals to three grounds
so that upper case has been fused okay
thank everybody for your time and thank
you again mr. Butterfield groves for
coming in today and your patience the
application was delayed from the
previous meeting with you apologize for
[Music]
but and so go to the next item
the go to ambleside and that's page 44
and mr. day's gonna give us an
introduction to this one page 44 40
humble side road Thank You chair I'll
just see if I can make plans up on the
screen it that it up on the screen now
no I can't see that yeah that's good
oh that's that's okay now yeah right
okay yeah application is being reported
through the committee because the
applicant is a council employee the
application prophet is attached through
story
swelling of 1930s design site is located
on Ambleside Road only residential Road
featuring a relatively uniform and
established street scene that down to
right is bounded by residential
properties on all sides
calling house has existing features a
front porch an extension and a
single-story flat roof re go
I'll just move on the proposed elevation
that's been thought to be demolished
we're doing the original front elevation
brickwork which has been made but the
existing single-story flat roof
outrigger is also to be
I think'll story extension is proposed
running along the majority of the width
of the plot and out from the original
dwelling house side elevation rocking
around the northeast corner of the
dwelling a hip tarrif is proposed on the
western side of the rear extension with
the eastern side elements of the
extension being a gable roof the
extension would have a rich height of
three point nine five meters and eaves
of two point seven meters walls and
windows are proposed on the rear
elevation and a reef light on the
violation leasing west the key
considerations are design and visual
amenity and the residents community of
neighboring property no objections have
been received the development is
compliant with SB d4 and it's considered
to be an appropriate height scale on
design and we're being keeping with the
street scene on the surrounding area
application is therefore recommended for
approval
we'd like us to remember that all
applications need to be it to be
assessed for we bind by members and I
know this was held over from previous
meeting and perhaps is straightforward
what just like it it can consider it
does any members wishing to speak to
this item
okay well out I'll speak to the item I I
went to view it for the previous meeting
a visit to the note I genuinely feel it
will be an improvement
to that side so certainly having no
issues with it
then I may say the front of the building
looks rather untidy and and this
application certainly rectifies that and
I'm sure is very welcome for the for the
applicants and for that family so I'm
very happy with it and and I'm happy to
move that we grant this application
anybody else like to comment so I'm not
reading my my chat facilitating
councillor Proctor thanks chair yeah
agree with you on on this I think it's a
very straightforward application I think
these are really good plans actually
there's no impact on I mean it's a we've
had no representation from the neighbors
from so I think from that we can assume
it they're happy with the plans yeah no
no should with it at all I'm happy to
agree this I think the only reason it's
probably here is because it's a member
of staff of Trafford thank you Joe
absolutely Thank You councillor Proctor
and so it's been moved and seconded that
we grant this application along with the
officer looking in Daisy and I need to
go through all your names and I'll try
my best not to forget Council it's
almost this time so I'll go to council
the dr. Barkley first
Thank You chair Thank You chairman I
support the officers recommendation to
grant Thank You councillor Kari and
grant please chairman Thank You council
accordingly support officers
recommendation Jeff
Thank You councillor Courtney councillor
Hartley and co-chair Support Officer
recommendation - great thank you
cancelled your own officer
recommendation to grant Thank You
councillor Morgan Thank You chair as for
officer recommendations to grant
Thank You councillor Proctor the ocean
is to blend Thank You councillor Rigby
and I did press to speak on that on the
previous one but I seem to be unable to
get your attention
yeah Bogey's fell across the rig beef if
you don't get my attention feel free to
shout out and councillor Williams and
support offers a recommendation to go
and I think counselor Thomas made them
before me as alright I'm going to get to
him I promise you that councilman
Stanley our support officers
recommendation chair - grant thank you
and councillor Thomas I can fully
support the opposite hope the officers
recommendation - Graham
thank you that's unanimous the
applications been grunting thank you
everybody for that I'm gonna go to the
next item and that is eight of each
closing sale on page 133 of your agendas
there's no speakers to this application
as I understand it
somebody wants to correct me
[Music]
we have an introduction from mr. Pearson
sorry mr. day yeah thank you sure I'll
just see if I can put this one on the
screen is that it's not showing now it's
showing yet yeah okay
again this application is being reported
to committee because the applicant is a
council employee the application relates
to a two-story detachable tea with a
double garage to its frontage and
additional parking provision three
further vehicles the application site is
of a regular configuration and backs on
Manor Avenue and a side and front
boundary daunted by to close the
property is located within a cul-de-sac
of detach pockets of varying design with
no formal building line move on to the
proposed plans little comprises the
erection of a single storey side
extension to the northern elevation of
the dwelling are the same as the
existing calling under width of 3.5
meters if these site would be 2.5 metres
with a gable roof design where the roof
pitch the same as they host building and
a maximum reach height of 5 meters
Bowman would be construction in similar
materials to the existing dwelling with
a window in the front elevation and by
folding doors in the rear and prepares a
secondary window is also on the side
elevation facing north the extension
would be approximately four meters from
the northern boundary at its front
corner reducing to about 2.6 meters at
the rear the key considerations are
design and visual immunity and the
residential amenity of neighbors no
objections have been received the
development is compliant with SPD 4 and
is considered to be able to appropriate
height scale and design which would be
even with the street scene and the
surrounding area if therefore
recommended for approval
Thank You mr. Gabe and I'm not seeing
the rest of the panel I sit around okay
this is another application it was held
over from the previous me needs him when
we overrun and any members wishing to
comment also Hartley as indicated
counselor hardly yes thank you I'm happy
to to move a motion that we agree with
the offer
officer recommendation to to grant this
application I went to look at the site
before the before the last meeting cause
I think it was postponed and I think I
think the report addresses the
application application well the design
is in keeping with the existing dwelling
and and there was no there's no impact
on the on the immunity of neighbors I
think the extension is is screened at
the front elevation by by the detached
garage that's there and the layout of
the of the estate is is such that it's
the house is at an angle to number six
which is next door and it's set further
forward and this there's a tall hedge
there at the moment which which provides
adequate screening so I don't think is
any impact on on residential immunity so
I there's no planning reason to refuse
the application that I can see so happy
to move to support the officer
recommendation chair thank you they
can't look according Lee do you want to
come in yes chair just a second I echo
everything that goes on Hartley said and
supporting for the officers okay thank
you for that counsel when Stanley used
to comment and now I will go to second
the application for everything that they
proposed and now second terms you said
okay thank you for that so it's been
moved in second that we grant this
application we'll have to go through
each member
buying them comes the doctor back way
Thank You chairman I support the
officers recommendation to grant cute
comes Meharry run please chairman Thank
You councillor Kari comes accordingly
supporting grant Thank You councillor
heartily agree with recommendation to
grant chair thank you thank you it comes
with your own the recommendation to grow
Thank You councillor Morgan Thank You
chairs fourths the recommendations to
grant
Proctor motion to grant Thank You
councillor Rigby Thank You council
Williams Thank You chair Support Officer
recommendations are gone Thank You
councillor wing Stanley I think Jeff's
for jobs recommendations ground and it
comes what Thomas I was fully support
the officers recommendation to grant
that's almost and I'm not be giving my
box here but I must have enough support
the application as well I don't have any
issues with it at all and it's a fine
application so the application had been
granted that's a unanimous decision by
the committee and we're gonna go to the
sale Western application now perhaps the
larger the largest application this
evening and just remind you what page of
your agenda that is on that's on page 70
of your agenda and we've got speakers to
this application but before we introduce
those speakers we've got miss Lowe's
he's gonna give us an introduction to
the whole application miss Lowe's
Thank You chair I'll just share my
screen and get the presentation up now
is that M is everyone able to see it now
yeah that's good thank you
and the application relates to the
redevelopment of the sail west estate
and proposes up to 263 new residential
homes the application has been submitted
in hybrid form with 79 new social rented
dwellings proposed in the full detailed
application phase 1 and an outline
application for up to an additional one
hundred and eighty four additional
dwellings of which at least 10% will be
affordable housing the additional works
proposed include the formation of a new
spiral road which can be seen on the
master plan drawing here and extending
from south all the way up to the north
of the site or the harry improvements to
improve west connectivity through the
estate the span rolled would connect the
northern part of epsom avenue down here
and silver part of the estate and a
connection on to ask us Avenue here in
in the northern part of the state and
Road connection of this nature of
president doesn't exist throughout the
estate these will involve the
construction of the first part of the
spine Road and will extend from Epson
Avenue joining to Hurst Avenue here
extends the landscape improvements are
proposed well throughout the estate
including the improvements of two
footpaths parking courts in areas shown
here here here and here and numerous
other ones throughout the estate and
tree planting with up to 119 new trees
to be planted and with 28 to be lost
within phase one alone all the
landscaping wakes around the estate the
formation of areas of new open space
particularly here and here ms wale along
the new spire road which will consist of
wildflower planting and an trees
other areas of informal seating and play
equipment within the wider area
improvements to the cell West Park and
the community center will also form part
of the outline and proposals and are
acceptable in principle the image now on
your screens and shows the new spam mode
as it would extend what within phase 1
and if you can see the residential
properties new residential properties on
and the eastern side of the road and
you've public footpaths through the
estate the area of Swale against the
spine road and the the landscaping
that's proposed throughout the state the
application proposes development on a
number of areas of open green space
within the estate number of these areas
have been previously Isabela
it's an originally host of dwellings
with in theory journal estate and
they've subsequently been demolished in
the areas have been left vacant areas
are shown in purple on the plans to
identify and then clearly for members so
whilst overall in quantitative terms the
amount of undeveloped land within the
estate is reduced by the development the
quality of the new landscaping is
considered to be significant as is the
usability of these spaces in terms of
the creation of play areas and informal
recreational areas for sitting out and
enjoyment it is considered that these
would greatly improve the quality within
the quality of the environment within
DST
sorry to asthma is this screen still
sharing is it a blank screen screen
sorry about that I just stopped sharing
for two seconds and I'll reopen that
apologies everybody
[Music]
[Music]
sorry I'm having difficulty getting that
back off and I'll just continue with em
the oral patient you know then I can get
plans of doing if members wish to see
them once they're in the debate thank
you the design along with the
landscaping and a streetcar parking
within the plots are considered to be of
high quality and I consider to relate
well to the existing estate enhancing
its visual the Manistee and providing
significant regenerative benefits on the
slides that I was going to show you and
demonstrated the integration of the
existing the existing houses with the
proposal on how they've drawn on the
features of the existing dwellings and
tried to incorporate that into a simple
form of development for the proposal it
is recognized however that the local
schools at both primary and secondary
level are oversubscribed the applicants
provided viability information that
demonstrates its unable to provide any
financial contributions towards an
education infrastructure they have
considered that it's unviable and
particularly as the very development
proposals heavily rely upon grant
funding this sad vast impact is weighed
in the planning balance the mandible
benefits of the proposed Valley
development in providing up to 263 new
dwellings of which 79 would be for
social rent in the face for faith and
further additional housing in the faith
in the later phases along with the
significant proportion of family sized
dwellings are considered to
significantly weigh in favor of the
development in addition the
contributions towards the regeneration
of the southwest estate through just
through modern designed house in
enhanced areas of open space and
enhanced connectivity with a strong
sense of place it is considered that the
benefits significantly outweigh the harm
and respected the lack of contribution
towards education and on this basis
offices are recommending approval
subjects and conditions and Rebecca's
just got the end the plans up now so um
we can't really just go back a few
Rebecca where we just got the kind of
fly through the CGI's and yeah so if we
just the next one down sorry yeah so
this was just really to demonstrate to
members the the designs and proposed for
for the houses in very simple brick form
and with extensive landscaping in
between hard surfaced areas if we flick
onto the next one and we can see on
corners we've got feature properties as
you can see there and what you dress
both street frontages and areas of
dedicated bin storage where it has to be
provided on the frontage and those are
landscaped and provided with the bricks
around and put move on to the next one
this just shows us at the corner where
Epsom Avenue will will will go into the
new spam Road and you can see what this
feature and corner property its fronting
on to that street frontage and you can
just see right hands back
is that it damn it miss long sorry sorry
did you yes yes
the sound went haywire then and okay so
we've got two speakers to supplication
and we've got miss Phillips who's
speaking against the application miss
Phillips are you are you present I am I
am yep Phillips you have 3 minutes we
look forward to your to your comments
thank you okay so we add raise raise
objections to the proposed planning
application being considered today
because of the following reasons with
reference to the National Planet policy
framework the community's concerns
expects expressed during consultation
were ignored and asked their chapter 3
paragraph 16 see the plans have not been
shaped by early proportionate or
effective management within the
community which means he was only
consulted and informed as an
afterthought and residents perceptions
of local needs and the most valued
features of the estate that should be
protected have been completely ignored
the local housing needs will not be
addressed by these proposed plans in the
current housing stock is in grave
disrepair residents are living in
squalid conditions riddled with them and
7.8 million proposed has no attached
plan or timeline to inform of how this
will be invested to ensure improvements
for the existing residents our Valley's
poor reputation and lack of competence
is well documented by residents on the
community social media groups and we do
not have faith in their ability to
manage such renovation or that the
existing housing stock will be improved
there is a negative impact on the green
space and mobility and access to local
immunities the open green space proposed
for most of the development is not
surplus to requirement and the loss
incurred is not replaced with equivalent
or better provision as per section 8
paragraph 97 the land is demonstrably
special to the community and holds
significant value being central location
for recreation safe mobility and
accessibility and shall be protected as
per section 8 paragraph 99 in 100 the
proposed tree road serves only to
benefit the proposed new homes and not
the existing community is the new world
will undermined quality of life and
increase their of crime disorder and
road safety as per section 8 paragraph
98 the proposed development does not
protect or enhance public rights-of-way
and access rather it makes it unsafe
noisy unhealthy and impacts on
recreation and community cohesion the
current layout of the estate already
encourages the community to walk it
promotes social interaction and provides
opportunities the meetings between
people who might not otherwise come into
contact with each of that closure of
pedestrian routes and backpacks
significantly extend the length of walks
to meet critical amenities such as local
shops bus stop schools and GP surgeries
the proposals and coverage those with
cars to use them contrary to chapter 8
paragraph 91 see because it will be
safer and quicker than the proposed
options to access local meat I mean it
is also impacting further on carbon
emissions access to schools is
negatively impacted assuming the 77 of
the 79 bills will be only homes in phase
1 alone the baseline minimum of children
factored into the area equates to 122
extra young people requiring school
admission locally and yet there are no
plans to address this finally they know
the negative impacts on our children and
their childhood is severe because of the
development because I'm sorry because of
their ability to enjoy the surroundings
in a recreational manner is is effects
that they'll be effectively living on a
building site for up to a 10 year period
the play area is allocated for close
communal areas have not been mentioned
as a priority and the age range that
they're suitable for or who will be
responsible for the maintenance and
health and safety of those areas by
failing to address our concerns it will
result in community divided as ideas
residents encroaching our needs and
restricts our freedoms there is ample
brownfield land that could be developed
to address the lack of affordable homes
in Trafford without impacting on our
community's health well-being and safety
thank you thank you miss Phillips do we
have miss Stratton Stratton
[Music]
can any of anybody advise me to be
Stratton this album Stratton
can you hear me mr. utter hello hello
yes you can hear me yes yes I can hear
you thank you
do you have three minutes mr. utter
thank you okay Thank You Chen good
evening counselors is with great
pleasure that I'm here this evening to
represent this project I'm the project
director for sale West should we be
granted permission we'll be responsible
for delivering fifty million pound
investment the master plan in front of
you is the first key step in this
ten-year investment program and the
planning permission today would mean
that the first eleven point four million
of funding can be secured so briefly
recap the sale best estate is one of the
most deprived neighborhoods a profit
it's long bit in the traffic local plan
as a priority we federation area and
this is the first opportunity over a
decade for us to deliver on those
operations Priebus must apply an attempt
failed viability liabilities though
inertia force now but this is not a
normal scheme and we have worked
tirelessly over last year to develop
Road proposals that can be delivered
this includes with eight million pounds
investment in infrastructure and
community benefits we all secured grant
funding we need to that will not only
provide new homes but will also invest
in the wider regeneration for all our
residents since last summer we have
engaged all our customers we've written
to everybody had one-to-one meeting with
Mellie we've created a residence group
called Street voice to help develop the
funds a comprehensive consultation
process has been undertaken this is
inform the plan to every stage and
changes have been made to reflect the
great suggestions that we've had we've
also consulted with many many
stakeholders including local members all
of the emergency services local schools
the health center our sail west and of
course traffic council with whom we have
lengthy pre-application discussions as a
result we've had extremely positive
feedback to summarize benefits of this
scheme starting in September this year
we will build 79 high-quality new homes
in phase on over the next two years
hundred percent
affordable and all of them social rates
new homes will have their own driveway
cycle power clean Invisibles will build
London lead we will use bacon Glen's use
the fly-tipping
and we to turn them into attractive play
areas we will resurface the adopted
roads and pavements you will get a lot
for trees and colorful quantity you will
get a separate cycle rates say for
walking you get we will invest in
produce we will deliver lots of social
value by providing jobs local people by
working for the sport design-build
supply areas and Lopes at fall in Phase
two we will we will invest another 7
million pounds improving every customer
received last year when they would
receive these improvements so to
conclude we are passionate and committed
to the live in this exciting project and
there are no planning reason to buy this
application to be approved I fully
support the officers recommendations
thank you thank you mr. Stratton thank
you very much and come to the Rigby I'd
like to begin the debate on this one
councillor again it's thanks jerilyn
thanks very much indeed
my immediate reaction was to really
welcome this application and I've lived
here for 40 odd years in sale and I know
the southwest the state would really
benefit from the regeneration as
outlined in this application however
having studied the report I realize the
serious of fact that the proposed 194
new dwellings will certainly have on
both primary schools as well as
secondary schools in the area the
hundred eighty-four new homes the
majority of which are two three and four
bedroom houses are family homes and it's
reasonably soon we anticipate the large
number of children probably over 200 may
be far more than that will need to be
offered a school place the report
clearly states on set
a 76 that both the local primary and
secondary schools in the area currently
oversubscribed and a financial
contribution is recommended to address
the shortfall it also states that
comments are discussed in more detail in
the report but finally but scarce on
page 166 on page 214 it states following
consultation with the council's
Education Department it has been
highlighted that there are significant
capacity issues within the immediate
area in respect of both primary and
secondary schools which are all over
subscribed it goes on to say that
additional dwellings were in this
location a likely to result in a harmful
impacts on education provision I repeat
harmful impact on education provision
the financial contribution is sold Oh II
see a 106 agreement has been suggested
the two sums involved four hundred and
twenty five thousand nine hundred and
fifty phase one and the figure of
between four hundred forty two thousand
five hundred fifty five and four hundred
seventy hundred thousand seven hundred
forty seven depending on the number of
residential units progressed I just
asked the question just how will these
sums of money solve the problem the
desperate shortfall in school places
mrs. Mann identified I am told and I
only got the report that weekend and
it's been difficult to make a great
number of enquiry students everywhere
shut down but I'm told it won't on page
175 on page hundred seventeen it states
the benefits arising from the scheme are
numerous and I agree with that and the
number of them can be given substantial
weights and I will agree with that but
the adverse effect relating to the
pressure on local school admissions and
the ability of development to fund
education infrastructure the miz' isn't
mentioned it is therefore considered
that it has been demonstrated that the
adverse impact of the development do not
sing
they can--they and demonstrably outweigh
the benefits really you know I do
scratch my head and say so children
without a school there's not significant
is that you know is where scowlers will
have to say to parents is that what we
have to say to parents that it's not
significant you know it's not just
parents on the southwest the state
either and I'll come to that because of
the migratory effects of this
developments of the hundred and forty
hundred eighty-four homes at the two
hundred plus children this effect will
have on those admissions it will also
affect parents and I can say this with a
sense of a person who's been involved in
education within the area for over
thirty years it'll impact on children
living in national mercy particularly in
the glaybels role down here the mercy
Road area broad Heath that woodlands
Brooklands and Priory Ward's all
children living in these areas will be
affected the suggested sections one or
six months you know I'll say again how
all these monies impact on providing
extra places you know the mummies will
not be a solution to the problem I would
respectfully mine members that the
responsibility to provide the schools
provide school places for children in
Trafford and I'm sure members know this
lies with the local authority and not
with the schools themselves I will
suggest that it is there's not
sufficient detail in the report to
identify the solution to a problem which
has been identified you know I don't
want to repair glib but there's more
detailed in the report covering trees
landscaping open spaces public transport
and cycle parking then the list of
solving the vital issue of lack of
school places you know what I really
want to support this application I
really do but I feel I can't without a
full and meaningful report that
addresses the very real dire situation
surrounding the
to school places which will arrive it's
an issue that this council not the
schools must address otherwise the
committee will be placing large numbers
of parents and children in the both an
unhappy and hopeless position I
therefore would like to move that this
application is deferred pending a full
report regarding the provision of school
places as surely this is a key issue
which must be addressed to allow members
of this committee it should pardon the
pun to make a more educated decision
Thank You Sharon Thank You councillor
Rigby then I think we listen to what the
members comments perhaps before we ask
miss loathe to comment on the council
Rigby's concerns if that's okay so and
got accounts Licari councillor carried
lettuce and thank you chairman and I
used to live on the southwest to stay
and I think most people know that I'm a
school teacher in the local school and
and one of the main reasons why people
do you move to Trafford is because of
our magnificent education system and it
just scares me that we're going to have
some massive issues here with with the
size of the schools area that's its
intake we'll have to shrink dramatically
so children have been brought up in that
area will not be able to go to some of
these local magnificence the schools and
the number of children and where they're
going to go
we need a full plan and that explicitly
says over the next few years what's
going to happen before what I would be
able to vote to support this application
you shouldn't I'll be second in
councilor Rigby's proposal for a
deferment until we have more information
Thank You counselor Thank You councillor
Kerry Council will you
thank you unfortunately I disagree with
the take we've just heard I'm extremely
excited to see this application before
this this evening I take on board
entirely what counsel is Carrie and Big
B have said and then but I trust that
officers will have a response so the
concerns that they've raised truth is
Chad
I've spoken timing time before at this
committee about the fact that in
Trafford we have a crisis of
availability of homes or more so than
that we have a crisis in the
availability of social vented and
affordable vented homes so I'm really
excited to see that in the third phase
of this develop opposed development we'd
see the delivery of 79 social vented
units and that would go no small way to
try and address the absolute crisis that
I just referred to before beyond I also
think that this is a really good
opportunity to address some of the
problems that you see arise in in the 1
billion type layout of the estate it's
not a typical of an over spell council
estate to have that sort of feature in a
way that it's laid out and what can
often happen is that it can create by
way of structure hot spots for
anti-social behavior to crop up so I'm
really pleased to see that a
comprehensive crime impact statement was
delivered and I think that opening up
the estate in the way that the poet was
can hopefully try to alleviate some of
the nuisance behavior that you can often
get in that era of development beyond
that I think seven million pounds of
additional spending investments the
estate including in kitchen and boiler
upgrades to the existing properties that
has to be well canned I think that the
planting of an additional 91 trees and
the first phase of the development is a
really great opportunity to green the
area further in light of the fact that
some of the grass grass areas are going
to be built upon my small areas of
concern and to only see to one bed flats
being included I'd like to see a greater
provision of one bed accommodation
particularly in light of the fact that
we still have people subject to the
June sucks but I hope that there'll be
the opportunity to try and rectify that
in later phases of the development
so in short Trevor I'm not going to be
supporting the recommendation to refuse
this and I will be moving instead that
we vote in line with our office of
recommendation and approves the
application tonight and just in closing
the one other thing I would like to say
and this is just being a provoked Eeyore
ward councillor here is that and I'd
quite like to see millions of pounds
worth of investment on my side of the
sail west to stay in below st. Martin's
were on the headway not been estate so
well buddy can take that on both I'll be
great thank you
the way not in state so we can say that
I'm probably thank you chuck Thank You
councillor Williams councillor wins
family I in turn share councillor
Williams as summarize many things that I
was going to say I'm quite excited by
this developments I know this to stay
quite well and the redesigns moodle's be
sensible particularly up around the the
extra roads put through because the
estate is announced at the moment just
have a feel of slack England looking
it's cut off from the rest of the it's
cut off the rest of Ceylon this will
give us a way to address that so one
repeats all different points which
councillor Williams has said what I
would like to do is to is to hold it on
on one point and that's around
accessibility which is my only real
issue with the plans because this this
this in the officers report as if
there's a really positive step forward
in paragraphs 160 to 165 where we're now
starting to talk about the public sector
quality duty in terms of general
accessibility when we look at when we
look at planning generally but there's
quite an odd comment made in the design
and accessibility statements if you
don't get an item 6.9 when we're talking
about the individual dwellings it says
that the approach routes to the
principal private entrance will be safe
and convenient for everyone including
old and disabled people and some
wheelchair users and my question reading
to the planning team is the
any way that we can provide a special
condition and the approval of this
because to actually say actually these
houses are not accessible to everybody
and say well that's okay so some
wheelchair users can use them to strike
me as being particularly inclusive it's
not something we would allow which we
were looking and even the protected
characteristic we would not say that
there are safe think it means access for
some women or for some black people we
just wouldn't say it so it's a question
really is no possibility to book further
condition on this around the design of
individual dwellings to move away from
the idea that they're only accessible to
some wheelchair users but accessible -
it's never going to be perfect but to
the majority wheelchair user or
something such Thank You chair thank you
I think
stirring up some questions for Miss
Lowe's there I'm gonna go to councillor
Proctor councillor props we'd like to
comment you know a quite a bit of water
Castle Williams and castle Winston
listen actually generally I think these
are very exciting plans if anyone knows
this don't know it fairly well that over
the years has been various plans mooted
which never came to fruition - so
actually to see this is it's quite a
relief really quite exciting overwrought
I think the good design there and the
layout is it's quite helpful
I mean that I I think there is Babu
designed at the moment and I think
anything that can be done would it would
improve that one by one so little
concern is the the amount of actually
social rent in this I know I like 79 but
I don't think that's nearly enough so
it's better than what we've got in many
areas it's a star I can say that and
there is there is some investment there
for the existing tenants as well in
terms of the new facilities so I think
it's a it's quite positive net in that
respect
obviously I listen to councillor Rigby
because I carry the education issue
is of concerts listen to what officers
have to say on that and what solutions
might be possible to remedy that problem
if you look at the actual objections a
bit been made many of the residents they
largely understood disruption caused and
on the delay of development and possible
impact on some services I can't really
see that I can see sort of positive
benefits from that and very little sort
negativity so overall I think it would
be a much beneficial thing for the
estate it would help a number of people
who need social housing I'd like to hear
about the education issue because I
think that it's a a major concern but
overall I think I'll be voting for the
for the new proposals Thank You chair
Thank You counsel counsel accordingly
thanks chair and I noticed in the the
report that the local flooding Authority
is objected to the proposal but there's
information in the additional
information I was struggling with all
that I just wondered if we could have an
explanation on that because I noticed
that he does have a lot of heart
standing this is not I mean we described
it as modern I would describe it as
probably modern twenty years ago the
homeless day
I want better I'd be honest I'm not
excited by it I'm going to support it
well I'm supporting it because we need
social housing and things like that and
I'm worried that we are getting over
over we'll take anything and I don't
think this is the best design but he's
far enough advanced that we're not going
to get anything more it doesn't it's
still an overspill estate and it's
becoming even more of an overspill
estate to me I take on board council
when stanley's points about
accessibility that bothers me I take on
but I don't see a lotta blue transport
integration it's very much a car baster
residential with not very many access to
sharps a feels very very it feels
old-fashioned to me to be honest and I
think we can do better but is so far
advanced that I don't think I'm going to
go back on that simply be I I do worried
that we accept things just because they
have a an affordable housing government
we can do better and I think other
boroughs are doing better with that
social housing offer these days the the
flood management is very important we've
seen what's happened this week this is
not atypical this is the new normal for
me and I do say a lot of hard standing
the flood authority of objected there is
some mediation in the additional
information report and I think the back
tracks a little but I'd like some talk
through on that because I don't fully
understand whether they're totally in
support of it at this stage whether
they're willing to give all the
approvals that are necessary thank you
Jeff Thank You councillor Courtney well
I'm just going to ask miss Lowe's to
come in and comment on some of the
questions that they may know we've got
two more speakers to come and possibly
that people might want to come back
again but just ask miss Lauder to
comment on what we've heard so far from
then there's mr. Lowe's yes Thank You
chair and I'll start with and the
education issue and I think the report
highlights that obviously there isn't
any any contribution towards education
in this regard and that is a harmful
impact of the development so I think
that's recognized and it's in the
planning balance that we've made that
judgments and that the harm is
outweighed by the benefits and
councillor Rigby talks about the the
financial contribution and what that
would actually provide for so um what
that usually do what that usually goes
for is is ways of extending existing
schools providing additional classrooms
for additional forms of entry and
there's obviously the wider proposals
for the Carrington allocation and the
potential for new schools and within
that area
that would be accessible and within the
catchment of sale west so it could be
the financial contributions if they
we're sort could go towards providing
those m new school facilities and just
looking at the education and comments
tours on the first phase of development
for the seventy-nine units there
suggests in a pupil yield of 28 and
pupils based on the m the mix of
dwellings and and that's on which the
the contribution is based the later
phases we don't know the form of
development and that it will take its
potentially would include older persons
accommodation and so obviously the pupil
yield on that would be significantly
lower than our standard standard housing
and so that so we've got we've got a
that's why we've got a variety of
contributions proposed but what offices
and conclusion is that whilst and this
is a harm there is arising from the
developments that it's not so
significant that outweighs the the
significant benefits of up to two
hundred and sixty three new units of
which a significant proportion are
affordable and moving on to the flood
risk issue and picking up on council
cordon these points there yes initially
and we had concerns and an objection
raised by the local lead and authority
on this and this was specifically
arranged around the drainage strategy
and the calculations that were provided
by the applicant and subsequent to their
publishing of the report the applicant
submitted some sufficient detail that
the the llf a was happy with the
calculations and the drainage strategy
the concern that they still have is
around how how and who will adopt and
maintain the sustainable urban drainage
and and the surface water and runoff and
so as I talked about in the presentation
there's a swale and proposed I am
adjacent to the new spine Road and in
all the car parking areas it's proposed
that in permeable paving is installed to
to deal with service water runoff
appropriately so whilst that's a concern
of the other FA and it's not a
considerable it's not
material planning consideration that we
feel is an issue as we've got adequate
conditions on that would require details
of the management and maintenance of all
surface water drainage and M swords to
be submitted to to the to the local
planning authority for approval and we
think that adequately mitigates and for
the lack of that information up presence
there's issues around whether be M the
local hiring Authority would adopt the
paintable paving and the Swale and
discussions are ongoing in that regard
and that's to be picked up as well on
the highway side of it through their
section two seven eight agreements with
the local Highways Authority so we think
this adequate mitigation in place and
procedures in place that would secure
and ensure that that's all appropriately
and looked after
once planning approval is if if planning
approval is granted and moving on to and
councilman Stanley's point around
accessibility and wheelchair users I
think we could definitely do something
in the regatta in in regards to that for
the outline application in terms of the
design of the new units particularly
around the potential for older persons
accommodation and that would obviously
need to be incorporated I'm just also
being sent some details around our draft
design guidance in relation to
wheelchair unit users and what that
recommends in line with building
regulations is that 10% of all new homes
are designed and to meet and building
regulations and are for wheelchair users
and so we can ensure that that is
adequately addressed within within this
scheme and and adds additional condition
to that effect if members consider that
appropriate okay thank you mr. Lowe's
for that before I bringing a counselor
heart like I just remind everybody that
councillor ribbing councillor Kerry what
they were about was deferring the
application for further information
about the education impact winner the
refusal do you want to talk about
deferring the application okay counselor
hardly you'd like to come in
Thank You chair yes I'm supportive of
the application and and for many of the
reasons that councillor Williams another
and other speakers have said a welcomed
application it provided much-needed
contribution to Trafford housing supply
which which were obviously way behind
schedule on 79 new houses in the in the
in the first phase all of which
affordable housing is also is also
really welcome I think generally desert
there's a good mix of Housing and now
kind of the Williams had some concerns
but which which I would would echo but I
think generally it's a good mix of
different housing units the second phase
adds up to a hundred and eighty four
houses and I can't find the reference
now in the report but included in that
is it's anticipated that there will be a
good proportion of social housing and
also I think there's mention of housing
for people with additional needs the
elderly and people with other needs
which again there's a great shortage of
in Trafford so that that will be very
welcome if that can be incorporated at a
later time I think the design of the
housing units is generally good I think
it will enhance the design of the estate
overall which is very you know is very
repetitive and sort of very a very very
sort of bland palette if I can put it
that way so it'd be a good contrast I
think to the housing that that is there
the phase two also sort of includes the
refurbishment the community center and
the games area agree with what's been
said about the estate layout which is
you know which is impenetrable
impenetrable at the moment and and the
proposals will will improve that I hear
I hear the concerns that people have
made about the spine road and the
weather to the to three roads that will
eventually result but there's a there's
a sort of a balance there isn't there I
think the effect of them will be to open
up the estate and and may make the load
more attractive and I think there are
measures in place to
to calm the traffic and to help with
road safety obviously appreciate that
this this proposal is to is to build the
the new housing units by by in filling
essentialist so in filling some green
spaces and in filling some other sort of
derelict spaces and sort of car parking
courts so it's creating a you know a
higher density of housing boots but I
think I think that's that's acceptable
so a lot of a lot of green space on the
estate is is not well used it's um I
suppose it's low quality is the way I
describe it you know so there are green
areas but they're they're quite they're
quite early so you can't sort of play
games games on them and if you like so
and pleased to say that you know
although the green space is being
reduced I think the green space that is
there is is you know it's much more
usable and residents will be able to
enjoy it a lot more and others concerns
about parking but I think they're
addressed in the report the new units
will have dedicated parking spaces for
the for the most part yeah I sort of
listen to what camps and council
accordingly said and you know I do think
we should have high high ambitions and
high aspirations for the affordable
housing that we deliver but I guess the
reality is that you know we this this in
a way is a good application and we're
not in a position where sail West could
be it could be started again you know
you we would do things very differently
if we could but you know clearly this is
a scheme which which the applicant can
afford and I think he's going to enhance
it's going to enhance the area unless
what councillor Rigby said about about
the about the education situation and it
is it is a matter of concern obviously
that the the applicant can't pay a
contribution through through a section
106 agreement that is that is a concern
but I think as we as we had in as we
heard in the advice from from the
officer
a concern that the council are gonna
have to address and obviously there are
you know this talk of proposals for more
housing and carrington so so having
extra school capacity in that area is
something the council are gonna going to
have to address anyway and I think that
you know there's as far as I can see
there isn't there isn't a planning
reason to to refuse this application the
report talks about a tilted balanced
test that we have to apply and although
the you know the lack of the
contribution to the to the today
education capacity is is a big concern I
do think it's far outweighed by the
benefits that this scheme will deliver
so I would agree with the recommendation
to to grant permission for this
application I had I have one query which
we shall raise and it may be that well
raise the query in and we can see how
drainage was a concern but I think
that's been addressed by the by the
additional information and it's a it's
quite a specific query but it was a bit
in the report that didn't just didn't
quite make sense to me which was around
the is the comments on the impact on on
residential amenity so it was paragraph
91 in the report which is talking about
particular particular plots in the
scheme and in paragraph 91 it seems to
say so this is talking about these are
these are detached two-story maisonette
buildings and it seems to say about half
if well but about five or six lines down
it seems to say the east-facing
elevation of a new building will have
bathroom window kitchen window to like
to lounge dining room windows on the
first floor facing 23 chepstow an
existing house and then it says given
the close proximity to the boundary its
proposed to obscured lays all the
first-floor windows on the eastern
elevation and that seemed a bit odd if
you had obscured lays windows for the
bathroom kitchen and to lounge down in
windows I'm not sure here that gives you
a livable space and
I suppose just compare and contrast that
today suggested condition to address
that which doesn't it doesn't seem
consistent with it I think it's
condition 15 that talks about obscure
glazing and where that's that's needed
and that doesn't seem to say the same
thing so so I'd welcome comments on that
I mean if they can't if we can clarify
it today we might be able to deal with
that by way of a allowing some
discretion to officers to agree a
suitable condition to to deal with the
issue there but thats all i wanted to
say chair so very sports with the
application thank you
Thank You councillor Hartley come Thomas
thank you Jeff yeah again broadly in
favor of the the number of houses being
brought to the community but I would
just heed the very eloquent three
minutes we got from I think as mr.
Phillips regarding the community we're
all talking about how the the present
plan of the the the area is the
residents in general do like that sort
of closed in if you like for one of a
better phrase rather than having to rap
runs through it will massively increase
the traffic in the area that is a
concern likewise the environment where
people can walk on to walk across now
through the estate to someone revenue
without having to cross any large roads
so I do think that going forward the
question of how much or how many of the
community are actually involved in the
consultation to get the plan right to
get the whole everybody behind you from
both sides if at all possible
again like i pickleberries point and the
fact that ten percent of these we're
gonna be accessible sure it has to be a
minimum we shouldn't have as many of
them accessible as possible
of the homes and finally education-wise
if they're all primary school children
it is quite a long way to go into the
Carrington
well the proposed Carrington site which
is probably a good 10 years 15 years
away and for children of that age to get
there what do we have in in school
building Stockman's been closed in the
past 10-15 years that we could perhaps
look at regenerating to bring class
sizes down perhaps house of thought or
otherwise pretty much am in favor of
anything that will give us up to at the
moment about 97 socially rented houses
thank you
Thank You councillor Thomas councillor
Morgan wait to come back
Morgan thanks Jer not to come back don't
think I've said everything yeah I
deliberately wanted to speak at the end
of the debate actually to listen to it
and I'm not gonna speak very long
because rather echo what sort of sad and
I I think there are concerns but in the
main I think the report addresses them
really well whether that being built on
some of the infill or parking issue I am
going to support this application but I
do share the concerns that councillor
Rigby accounts for Kerry have said about
school places I'm sure most of the
committee are either school governors or
parents or grandparents and and know the
issues and we have about school places
in Trafford and it's the real issue and
concern and I'm sure one that we're all
aware of but it's a balancing act and I
can't see being able to oppose the this
development some given the real benefits
it brings because of that issue but I
really want to put on record I think we
do need to address it and I do just
agree we walk
Thomas has just said about the distance
and the timings that in the Carrington
option and I think it's something that
we really do need to consider and and
think about where one on this vote but
yeah I will be supporting thank you
Thank You councillor Morgan counselor
dr. Barkley Thank You chairman it is a
really difficult balancing act and and I
can understand the concerns of councilor
carrying counselor Rigby completely is a
real concern but there was some thing I
would like to mention which hasn't been
brought up we we've heard that this
development is going to have an impact
on the present residents within South
West and I do feel that there's
something quite galling about the fact
that the residents are experiencing dump
in their properties and obviously those
homes are in need of repair and
improvement and whilst this new
development goes ahead and builds brand
new houses and I think that's quite cool
in giving it's going to be the same
property developer so I just wondered if
there is any scope if the committee
would support it or there's any scope at
all within the planning kind of
regulations and the planning application
if some of the section 106 monies can go
towards improving the current stock of
housing that's there because I do think
it's only equitable that we look at that
as the new houses go up that the current
houses should also be in the best stay
that they're in and I'm not sure that's
something we can address it does it's
just something that concerns me
Thank You chairman thank you dr. Barkley
if we just hang firewood for Sarah for
me it comes with your own monster to
comment comes with your own I think he
comes in two phases and I think over
always I think it works out as my
Master's right as 37% and the
requirement is for 20% in this this area
so though I think that's good I don't
think it's outstanding and not as good
as some of the applications we've seen
and whether we're the affordable housing
has been much higher so um you know
it's good but not great and also I think
in this application it talks about the
transport management plan which needs to
be updated and it also talks about
walking and cycling connectivity but yet
there's no evidence anywhere in this
application of what that will be it's
just an aspiration and I think deferring
this application would actually be a
good idea because it would allow the
developer to go off and give us some
answers to some of these questions on
the education on the walking or cycling
routes and this is a great area for
linking up walking and cycling that you
could link it up really successfully to
the Stanford estate in brought ace you
could link it up to you know flix Dhin
so I would like to see a lot more on the
public transport the psychic cycling and
walking I would like to see the
affordable housing actually go up the
Missouri 7% if I've got that right
because I think that's still quite low
for the development of this nature
so yeah I'm quite tempted to actually
support the deferring of this
application Thank You chair okay Thank
You councillor Jerome I've got two more
speakers and I really want to to move on
we need to get through the business
today but councillor Rigby and I've got
counselling Stanley won't want to come
back I'll just wait before I do I'd like
miss loath to comment on some other
questions that have just been generated
if you can miss Louis and yes of course
and in response to and council Hartley's
endpoint and on the plots identified in
paragraph 91 and I think what the report
is trying to say is that there's a
number of windows on the eastern
elevation in first floor but but those
that that living kitchen dining area has
an additional window on the South
elevation which will be clear glazed and
wouldn't need obscure glazing so that
room would still benefit from adequate
outlook and the condition has been
updated within the additional
information report to reflect that and
so I think and that addresses that that
issue and provides sufficient outlook
for for residents in in that particular
implant
on in councillor Barclays point around
the existing homes and there is no
section 106 contributions sort through
this scheme but what Abel Valley have
committed to do outside of this planning
application is 7 million pounds worth of
improvements to existing homes and I
believe I think it was Emery Ann's
introduction that all residents affected
by that have been written to him to
inform them of what form that takes and
when and how that will be implemented in
the future as part of this wider master
buying and project for the whole estate
okay thank you miss lower the winter
bring game council once down leave first
and then we're gonna have council
arrythmias the last week into this
application to a councilman Stanley
thank you thank for what councillor
William said about 10% is the minimum
aspiration if you go over if you've got
a sympathetic developer like their wall
valley certainly experience in other
parts of the country for the developers
is you can go beyond building
regulations in terms of the number of
accessible house because they'll be open
to work and we trap it on this that's
all I wanted to say ok thanks Jerry
Thank You council nice family counselor
Rigby the final word I just wanted to
impress it on colleagues that I'm not
against this application I think it is
quite an exciting application but with
my history in education in this locality
and then I say council Williams
Ward imparting to where I spent several
years improving education there with
others and the situation existing
included for disadvantaged children
which you know I've always made it on
giving them the opportunity of Education
is so paramount to say it must be sorted
in the future yes it must but I was
looking for us just to defer why we come
with an absolute strategy an absolute
strategy
nothing's impossible in life and I think
this application are
could kickstart some meaningful
application to cater for the shortfall
which currently exists on which room
this application will certainly increase
the demand for school places Under
Armour I do
Thank You councillor Rigby okay it has
it been moved in second year I think it
has council Williams moved it and I
think
did someone second a councillor proc to
the deuce second the application wasn't
you you right somebody would like to
second the application
okay well I'll second the application I
have heard her did you pay up and I'm
not commenting and and the answer is is
checks and balances and easy its way no
the greater benefit and councillor Rigby
talks with authority about education but
I think we're always gonna have the
shortage of skilled places entrusted
that that that that's something we'll
always have them and and perhaps is a
good thing people want some want to live
in the borough but the benefits of this
out outweigh that I think at this time I
think I think we need this housing and
all the new housing phase one is
affordable and that's very very welcomed
about comments about do we need to take
the bulb for it if there's been moved
and seconded that we defer the
application so well we'll do that we'll
save that deferral first so all those in
favor defer and I'll go through you
individually all those in favor of
deferral counselor dr. Barclay no
Chairman I don't support different roles
okay it comes for Kerry I could support
the deferral please queue Council
accordingly queue comes for Hartley
against state deferral thank you okay
Thank You councillor Morgan I don't
support the deferral Joe thank you
you councillor Proctor you Counsell
Williams against the default er Thank
You councillor Winstanley
I thank you Joe against you Farrell
Thank You councillor Thomas can't hear
you councillor Thomas you're on mute I
don't deferral voucher against de Ferrol
thank you and I'm gainst deferral so
that application has not been if I can
say granted deferral that makes sense
only two people vote in your favor of
deferral so we're going cuz I Rigby how
do you come to rig the apologies that's
the Rigby surprise you Thank You Rigby
okay so two people voting against rubber
in favor of deferral and the majority of
people against deferral so that has been
lost
we'll go for the granting of the
application then comes with dr. Barkley
Thank You chairman I support the
officers recommendation to grant you
councillor Kerry I support the officers
recommendation to grant Kerry comes
recording way support officers
recommendation to the end Hugh comes to
heartily I support the officers
recommendation to grant Thank You
councillor Jerome thanks Jay Thank You
councillor Morgan sport author officer
recommendations to grant chair Thank You
councillor proctor to grant
Thank You councillor Rigby Thank You
councillor Williams
poor officer recommendation to Gwen
thank you counseling Stanley Thank You
Jess for the officers recommendations
grant thank you and councillor Thomas
support for the officers recommendations
Grimm thank you and I'll support the
officers recommendation sit around so
that's unanimous thank you everybody for
your contributions I think that was a
healthy debate on that application I
think we'll go to we'll go to Pinewood
and we've got counselor and Steve
looking to speak to this and that's page
20 of your paper agenda ten Pinewood
Bolden and mr. Cola is gonna give us an
introduction mr. :
Thank You chairman if you just bear with
me when I get get the so this
application relates to the sight of a
detached 1970s dwelling which sits at
the end of a residential cul-de-sac in
the bone and conservation area you can
see it edged in red just there it's
located in the southwest of a pair of a
greater list if it victorious enemies
which are this pair of sorry it's a pair
of other units here and otherwise
bounded by residential properties on all
sides the applicant proposes to
redevelop the site provide two detached
houses in its place they would have five
bedrooms and they would have siding
single-story rear elements internal
garages and rear-facing dormers that
dasu be landscaping works around the
application's reported to committee
because we've hadn't stick classes
objection country to our officer
recommendation for approval I just take
you through some of these plans about
the elevations of the properties here
they are they're handed that's the side
elevation so see right there it's the
rear elevation and there and the other
side
well plans see how that sets out the
upper floor and these are street scenes
through so that the properties are here
if you can see my cursor in the middle
and you can see that it cuts through two
properties to the rear and you can see
the rest of I'm went there and again see
properties on Pinewood there with with
the t's Beyond and rear and there's some
CGI images of what development could
look like that from again from from the
rear so the main consideration in this
application is the principle of the
residential development together with
heritage design a residential amenity
impacts and officers have considered the
application we think it would be
acceptable designed and wouldn't
unacceptably impact on on the community
of neighbors
we're not identified any harm to the
Boden conservation of area from the
proposals and less lesser substantial
harm at the very lower end of the scale
that nearby listed buildings the public
benefits of the development are because
it is to about wave this harm and
officers have no highways concerned on
that basis the application is
recommendable Thank You chairman thank
you mister : do we have to do Morton
against the application we don't but he
has asked that a statement be read out
and maslow's is going to read that out
on his behalf
thank you Miss Lowe's thank you thank
you I'll now read out the and the
statement dear members we've already
sent our objections to the plans and we
totally agree with what other objectors
have submitted number 10 is a prime pot
on prime woods and yet if the plans are
passed we shall see what appears to be
more or less to semi-detached houses
with little or no open space at the
front only paved areas for car parking
and little else where our visitors going
to park there is already national
interest in banning all cars from
parking on pavements the plans indicate
attic rooms whereas in reality they in
effect give another story we have
all about the plans go into the
interested parties in order to pass this
development on number 10 but what about
the residents thoughts and objections we
have lived longer than anyone else on
Pinewood a third of the plots are lived
in by the original families and of the
others many families have lived here a
long time very few have moved on the
plots are large with a detached property
on each and are open plan frontages
through the deeds in this case the
developer has taken little notice of
neighboring properties due to the style
of the proposed two new dwellings and as
such as inappropriate development of the
plot mansion has been made of the
council's need to improve their house
build target this target is for
affordable housing not for two houses on
a plot in Pinewood if these plans are
passed it will open the door for the
developers to do likewise when another
house comes up for sale we ask very
strongly for the members of the Planning
Committee to recognize this and reject
the plans as they are this together with
two houses and their style is a concern
of everybody here if number 10 has to
come down we would support the building
of another detached house on the same
footprint with an open-plan frontage
your sister Sarah Lee Andrew and Lucy
Morton mr. Lowe's comes to answer that
you'd like to speak against this
application I hope you can hear me and
in making this representation I'm doing
so on behalf of the objections that have
been received by the council in relation
to this planning application and just
before I set out some of those remarks I
think that is an acknowledgment that
they rivet the revised proposals have
made progress but the principle of the
objections that we'll put in by my
residents remain unincluded about that
plan would sits within the heritage
asset of the devas Dale conservation
area that should be a material
consideration when considering the
appropriateness and of the application
and three main concerns have been
represented to the authority
specifically in relation to the
subdivision of the plot this would be
the only plot on the Pinewood that has
been divided into two and that
fundamentally changes character in their
view of the street and
would set a precedent on prime-time wood
in the surrounding areas for that to be
the case there is obviously recognition
that has been development of homes on
Pine Ward over many years now and the
acknowledgement that was just made from
the previous representation that
development is going to occur for very
real concern that exists around the
subdivision of the plot secondly that in
relation to highways considerations it
is surprising that the view of the
Highways Authority is that there would
not be no material and points for them
to raise and this is clearly with two
properties is significant greater
quantity than one property and in terms
of the volume of traffic that would then
be going up and down by more and it's
really important that members consider
that in determining at the application
and thirdly it was in relation to the
footprint and the footprint of the two
properties is smaller than the original
proposals but is still larger than the
existing footprint that the property
sits on and so those three concerns
continue to be raised and as points
material points for consideration by
committee in the letter of
representation that was sent by the
Bowden conservation group there have
also commented specifically in relation
to the conservation area appraisal which
talks about that selection a to make the
importance of ensuring original plot
boundaries being maintained and so
although the division of existing last
properties into smaller units may be
acceptable and providing there's no
detrimental effects the exteriors of the
property that is not the case here this
is the two properties that would be
slightly larger than the existing plot
as it is today and then the policy
objectives that I set out in the area
management plan and for the conservation
area and so I wanted to be able to sort
of speak today because I think at the
office the report has gone some way to
address some of those concerns or those
concerns in the view in the view of the
of the objection objectors continue to
remain and and that in command that
therefore there are sufficient reasons
and for the intensity of development and
the appropriateness of development to
constitute
and going against the officer
recommendation as has been poor today
and and it was very important I think to
particularly highlight the subdivision
the highways concerns and the footprint
concerns and to the attention of members
of the committee and for the debate that
is going to ensue and therefore it's the
request and will of indeed the Google
you have made representations to the
council and immediate neighbors on
Pinewood that the application is refused
and this evening thank you
Thank You councillor and state before I
bring in mr. Flanagan mr. Kaul he wanted
to advise us of something mr. Connolly
yes apologist chairman in my
introduction I said the site was in the
Boden conservation area councillor
Anstey's there referenced the Devas Dale
conservation areas in fact correct sir
Paula jeez for that well done comes the
Rams game mr. Flanagan you'd like to
speak in favor of the application mr.
Flanagan you there yes yes mr. Flanagan
closely with the council is appropriate
for the site and raises no planning
issues pre-application consultation was
undertaken also has been extensive
dialogue during the application process
which was resource having changes
through this game these changes have
been volved a reduction in the
footprints and height of the proposed
housing they're repositioning to ensure
an adequate cap is provided between
between them whilst the sense of
spaciousness is maintained within the
site and changes to the external
appearance of the houses for the use of
traditional materials a conservation
style applies the proposed houses are a
high-quality design which respects their
surroundings including enabling housing
them as their conservation area and a
grade 2 listed building on Park Road the
sensitive design of the houses which
have been adaptive in response to
comments from the council's conservation
officer ensures that they will have no
impact on the character
and the pills at the conservation area
or on the setting of the nearby listed
building the skin will provide a series
of planning benefits these include the
redevelopment of a brownfield site a
replacement of a single dwelling with
two dwellings which will contribute to
addressing the poorest I was in
shortfall a provision of an additional
house in an established residential area
which is located in a sustainable
location with access to public transport
links local schools community facilities
the provision of sleep family houses for
which to which there's a need and this
parts of the borough
each house is of a good size with fronts
amaura gardens and plenty of space to
accommodate afro parking
the houses are of a high quality
sensitive design better footprint is
similar to that of the existing property
they are lower in height than a system
property and they're both scale muscle
that's enabling dwellings there will be
no impact on the immunity of
neighborhood residents the various
privacy distances sets out the policy
guidance being adhered to the scheme
will not result in any hounds of the
natural environment
on the contrary six additional trees are
to be planted in society biodiversity
enhancement measures are incorporated
into the developments in summering the
scheme Accords at national and local
climate policy guidance and houses
support of the council's planning
conservation and highways officers the
applicants team of work rights include
with the council the developer sensitive
development which fits in with the
concepts and will provide much-needed
family housing we therefore hope that
the committee agree with their offices
and Q mr. Flannagan Glamorgan you'd like
to speak come to the Morgan and Thank
You chair and I'm going to disagree with
officer recommendations here and when I
looked at this scheme I'm slightly
surprised given its in the conservation
area that it's coming to us and and I
have to say doesn't I listen to the
initial representations
they were made and the things may change
my view on this I really do feel it is a
no development to that site you could
that site fit those properties yes and
if this was somewhere else in the
borough
you know these would be very big plots
but this completely changes the
structure of the Pinewood Road and it is
a small road with very big properties
but I honestly do feel this is just
picking a plot squeezing to two houses
on and and I honestly it doesn't fit the
disease your designs they don't fit in
with what's curly there and the
footprint is completely different and if
we're going to approve there I honestly
don't see why what the why we have a
conservation area so I'm gonna propose
that we reject officer recommendations
and yeah I mean that is really my view
it's a conservation if it's a
conservation area then I think we need
to say that into consideration
thank you Thank You councillor Morgan
counselor dr. Barkley Thank You Chan it
is always really good to increase and
the housing stock and within abode and
ward I know this a lovely place to have
houses and we always want to have more
but I'm going to agree with counsel and
Morgan and Councilman City who made the
original presentation against the
application because actually I think
that the development of two houses in
one space is not over over development
for the road it's and it's also just
over development and in appropriate
development when you look at the actual
design of the houses if they just don't
seem to fit within but you know the
other houses along Pinewood they they
all are overlooked and I don't think
they fit so I think it's a development
I don't think and they fit in with the
remaining houses on Pinewood and because
of its unique position I think really
when you get around the bend and see
plots I think it's the first thing that
your eyes are drawn upon me is very much
a focal point and I think
really changes the whole layout of the
road I think it changes the feel of the
road I think it sticks out it will stick
out I mean I stopped looking at the pot
and imagining it and I really did feel
that it was two houses on that plan
would look really incongruous compared
to the rest of the street so and I am
for I mean I understand that officers
don't see any objections but for me I
think it's inappropriate developments
it's over development for the sides and
it is also really narrow road and we're
going to have a loss of extra vehicles
coming in and out and I know there's no
highways objections but that's just
another thing I think in which goes
against this development for me so I
will be actually going against officers
recommendation Thank You chairman Thank
You councillor dr. Buckley council
accordingly
I think they've done a good job in
working with the applicant I was taken
by a council announced this point about
allowing subdivision of an existing
building into to swelling but not new
build and in some way I've struggled
with that because no building lasts
forever and the structure of a two
building it's inevitable that at some
point though those two buildings will
become two new buildings at some point
so III think this is an acceptable
development you know the conservation
officer we should abide by in this and I
think I could propose acceptance Thank
You council accordingly councillor when
Stanley yeah second acceptance of
officers recommendations when I went to
do the site visit the thing is we can
bring the plans beforehand and seeing
the cui representations is I don't think
it would change the only would be a
jarring on the landscape I really don't
it only you would change the car to the
road at all sigelei is just next to the
just next tombs finally obviously at the
site that's going to be developed
already a big three story has been
developer looks like it's on a bigger
footprint than the orig
that the original footprint that was
that so and it in terms of the rest the
objections raised by the neighbor so say
armand massing in scale I don't think it
will change it trees and landscaping
you've all been addressed in the report
I don't there's no parking on that road
at all what we're talking about is one
extra house in a road which is already
we've had a lots of space when it's
already so I will be I'll be second in
the UM be supportive of the understand
sorry I'll be second in the support in
the offices recommendation thank you
sure Thank You councilman stanley
councillor jerome application and I
think his counselor when Stanley said
and many of the objections don't really
hold up and I think you've got
objections such as traffic parking and
we you know I don't think there really
is a problem and it's quite a quiet road
quite a wide ride and I don't think
there won't be a problem here it's not
particularly overbearing as a report
that says there is no higher as other
buildings in the area and I don't think
it would have any detriment to property
values as some of the objections of I've
mentioned but I think and one of the big
problems in there then is the CGI it
doesn't do do the application any favors
but if you look at the landscaping plan
it will actually add extra trees to the
plot and though this plot is being
subdivided it is actually a very big
plot like all the adjoining houses which
are also on big plots and I think if you
look at the Heritage Development Officer
and he does say quite clearly that there
won't be any harm to the character and
appearance of the diversity of
Conservation Area and he said there will
be some big little harm to the aesthetic
of the den hill and the Old Vicarage but
they are quite and screened from this
development anyway so I can't really see
a problem with this development being
being approved
thanks Jay
Thank You counselor Jerome got one last
speaker to this item counselor Hartley
and counselor Thomas indicated he'd like
to speak counselor Thomas would you like
to come in I'm happy to step aside for
counsel Harley Thank You counselor
Thomas counselor heartily Thank You
chair I'll support the officers
recommendation the application for
reasons that the others have given
really so I mean the listed the listed
buildings are sort of just about visible
certainly from the front of the plot
which which was all lack of view when I
when I went down there so I think the
you know any harm to those heritage
assets is negligible and and I don't I
don't think you know it creates any more
any more harm to that setting than than
the house that's already there I don't
think the designs for the house is a
remarkable to be honest but but it's
it's without without being offensive to
the residents that are there that
there's nothing remarkable about a lot
of the houses on the streets you know
there are certain character they're big
it's very very open boundaries but
there's a mixture of sort of you know
70's 80's and very new build houses that
are there so so this this proposal won't
look out of place I don't think on that
Street at the other concerns that I
don't think I'm a doubt other people
have covered that so so I'll be
supporting the officer recommendation
thank you I think it's the heart I'm
just conscious everybody that we've got
business to get through to yet so we'll
take the refusal first be moved into
thinking that we refuse this application
counselor dr. Barkley and thank you
chairman I support refusal councillor
Kerry I support refusal Thank You
chairman Thank You council accordingly
reject refusals refusal councilor
Hartley against refusal Thank You
councillor Jerome Thank You councillor
Morgan or refusal or refusal councillor
for refusal councillor Williams reject
refusal get refusal councilman Stanley
Thank You Jo engaged refusal thank you
and I'll be against refusal so the
refusal in lost so we'll go to the
granting of the application that
Lawrence we need to do that sorry Thomas
yeah I I'm against it's bad with me
against refusal entry future apologies
counselor I'm against and I forgot you
believe all counts the proper time
getting carried away trying to move move
was on to our business miss Cole we do
you want to comment just to say that we
need to take the opposite record the
opposite now right okay counselor dr.
Barkley I'm sorr refused
Thank You chairman at refused yes
counselor Carrie refused please chairman
choose Thank You councillor Carrie
counselor halfway a grant application
thank you ucomfy canceled your own
foundation to go on prove Thank You
councillor Morgan thanks Jo reviews to
the proper to run the application chair
patient's Thank You councillor Rigby
refused the application counselor
Williams approved the application show
the application thank you
then councilman Stanley Thank You Jenna
prove the application prove the
application Thank You councillor Thomas
I prove the application the application
and I'll be voting to approve the
application so that okay so will I check
comes recorded this time council
accordingly polishes everybody counts
the car really
I approve you prove thanks counselor for
me that application have been approved
everybody thanks you thank you for your
discussions and thank you everybody for
your contributions okay and we've got
one speaker left
councillor jam and I believe so we'll go
to that
applicationnow and misnomer is going to
give us an introduction but I'll just
give you the page number that is page 13
on your paper agenda long to the west of
Seymour Grove and miss mill me you're
going to give us an introduction miss
Millman thank you yeah I'll just share
my screen view so you can see a
presentation so I hope you can all see
the the presentation now on your screen
she so yep next application for is
relates to a lot and so links to a
larger retail unit with a car park
adjacent to the traffic bar Metrolink
station to the north the car park is
partially border to the east by a
terrace of properties which went on to
see more Grove separated by a service
alley these properties are commercial at
ground floor and residential above
present there's no boundary treatment
between the car park and the rear of the
terrace properties throwing permission
is sought for the erection of a 2 meter
high V mesh fence finished in green
which was extended on the eastern
boundary of the carpark south side of
the Seymour Grove Terrace the sim the
phones would be a similar height and
design develop along the north side the
car park adjacent to else in North Road
amended plans have been submitted
digitally three pedestrian access points
through the fence between the car park
and the service alley
the application is reporters committee
has it been called in by council Jarman
due to concerns about waste collection
and in support of the objections
received which at least raise matters
regarding access for waste deliveries
and emergency vehicles and also
concerned about the environment it
requests along the alleyway and the
environment for tenants we've been the
terrorists both commercial and
residential and the future viability of
these units the key considerations for
offices are principal development the
design and appearance of the fencing and
impact on the wider area and
presidential amend
along with waste collection officers
consider that offenses in keeping the
area being along the boundary of the
carpark and having consulted colleagues
within our waste department they raised
no objection and the service alley is
over two metres wide and therefore would
retain bins to be moved along the
application is therefore recommended for
approval I'm just just photographs I'm
suing as we need to show the service
alley on the carpark and that's the
fence elsewhere thank you okay thank you
Miss nomer and two speakers again sis am
i right thinking mr. green he's not with
us
no but he's asked for his representation
to be read out and I'm ready to do that
Chandler if you'd like to do that mr. :
yes
the rate of shops and c18 an unhealthy
and unworkable environment would have
repercussions for the owners and tenants
of the properties there are already
loading restrictions in place at the
front of the properties so the back has
being used for all types of access over
the last 30 years ever since the site
was built one of the activities for the
shops and flats is the refuse collection
there are I think 30 shop properties
using commercial bins some total
property in gray domestic bins for the
flats the erection of the fence for
three openings at nine hundred mill for
access would not allow the refuse
collectors to collect the bins the bins
measure in hundred and five centimeters
by 20 centimeters so at 76 centimeters
times 125 centimeters with the pavement
in 180 centimeters things would not be
able to be past each other or some not
even as the openings the bins would then
have to be moved to the far end of
pavement opening on to Elsinore Road
these are going to prove impossible the
access for tenants the flats would prove
to be very difficult to negotiating a
narrower they would bins blocking the
way of course for concern about safety
of people - as the back would become a
place where there would be nooks and
crannies created by all the bins their
access for maintenance that's very very
difficult - and the emergency services
would really struggle as well the shops
and flats could become a less able
the desirability became less this would
lead to the area being blighted I'm sure
this isn't what traffic council would
like council need to work with people of
the area to make it better not worse
Council as far as I'm aware owned the
site and lease it they must have a
saying what happens there for the
benefit community an issue with the car
park and the refuse you only have to
visit the site to see what an eyesore it
is the people who own the site are
trying to get an answer
however this can't be it another way has
to be resolved regards Lawrence green
Thank You chairman give mr. Conway
councillor Jarmon you'd like to speak to
this application yeah thank you Jeff
thank you ma'am another committee and
the reason I called this in was mr.
green contacted me I think probably
originally in December when it was
originally put out for consultation
because he was against the and so on
Wade collection grounds now obviously
it's been it's been amended and he still
has issues which which miss Coley
outlined in in his in his written
submission so really I'm just
highlighting appointing the committee
towards the aspects of the of his
submission really that need need to be
addressed so as you mentioned the
properties are of no provision for bin
storage or collection at the front of
the properties oh by the way he's a
resident he's a business resident I
think at number 28 of that block 20 AC
more grow the that block has no access
for bin collection at the front or
access for refugee collection from the
Braun so all the servicing needs to need
to be done from the back now it in the
fencing the the three openings I believe
it's three openings have been have been
widened to 900 millimeters for the bins
to be collected no we don't the mr.
greens been out there with his tape
measure which is which is
good information in he's saying that the
bins a hundred and sorry 1200 1200 by
1050 millimeters 760 by 1250 millimeters
therefore some of the bins just wouldn't
fit through through the openings so we
don't really know how that's gonna work
there are parently 13 properties there
some some of which are two of the Euro
bins which are used for the businesses
there's also the gray domestic things
for the flats the pate the pavement is
only a 1,800 millimeters wide so it
doesn't seem the sufficient room for
pedestrians pedestrian access and the
bins to to sort of move past each other
behind the fence as well as access for
things like deliveries maintenance and
also emergency services now I believe
that commercial properties hire their
own waste collection so that would that
would mean that there would be different
different waste collectors coming at
different times so all that all the bins
would have to sort of move past each
other and we doesn't it doesn't seem to
be sufficient sufficient room plus also
the the gray domestic things in the
report says that the the waste
management have made have made no or
have no objection but I'm just wondering
whether that as a positive assurance
that the bins actually can be collected
or it's just it's just a case of no
common and it might be the ami can
collect the gray bins but whether
whether the whether the commercial waste
collectors can can collect the actual
the uro things you know ISM is a matter
of concern so I don't actually know
who's been who's been consulted but I
think really that it really needs to be
looked up so obviously I would point to
his written submission obvi she's not
here here to speak I didn't know whether
he would be already wouldn't but he
seemed to it seemed too old to leap
between the two but he's obviously more
on top of the detail than I am because
he actually lives there and he's
obviously made his own investigation so
I think you know there was sufficient
evidence there that you know perhaps
render that the waste collection is
actually unobtainable or unworkable from
from what he said so under the present
proposal so I think really we need to
take a step back and probably have
another look at it and so I would move
refused I'll ask you to refuse sorry
okay Thank You councillor Jam when
you've had over you five minutes
actually
okay any members wishing to comment my
picture seems to have frozen I don't
know if you can hear me I can hear you
right if nobody wishes to comment there
now I'll make some comments um I hear
what counts the Chairman seems to me
that the businesses are using the land
as a means to store their bins or to
help them get their bins emptied and I
don't think should refuse his up there
okay you know I think it's play from
their land and I've know I've no issues
with that and it seems to be that
there's a understanding that the land is
used said to help with the refuse
collection but um that that's something
that's been enjoyed but I don't think
he's that it stands up against the
planning application and so I think it's
sort of a local issue if you like and
counsel according is like to come in
Council accordingly yes and mister was
it mr. green long screen there it is
summation he raised the issue of whether
the council owned the land and I could
do with that being clarified and the
bins are I I do have problems with this
counselor whilst you will know the
problems we have in Gore Sullivan alley
and we're creating an alley behind shops
here we've over the shop plants and that
is one of the issues that is going to be
a problem so I was disappointed in waste
disposal saying this wasn't going to
cause problems I think he's going to
cause huge problems but I don't think we
have a planning response to that I don't
think we have grounds to do it with the
waste disposal suggesting it won't be
any issues these are collage commercial
waste bins that are used by takeaways
we have it they won't get past each
other easily we're creating a combined
space for them and that will be a
problem as we have experienced in
yourself and will continue to experience
it it's a problem these commercial waste
bins in in such an area particularly
while coronaviruses on and some of the
businesses in lockdown but the I think I
will just support they the acceptance at
the officers report on provider we can
clear the Trafford and ownership because
I do think if we own the land then we
should have a saying that misnomer would
like to comment yes notice has been
served on tractor definiteness several
landowners that merge here so notice has
been certificate B has been served on
this application and from my
measurements date alleyway is two point
three meters wide and yes it might be
struggle but bins would be able to move
past because the fence line is inside
that's my space understanding is
properly so your what you say miss mills
you do you believe with the fence being
up as two of these your opens could pass
each other farmers parks what one would
pull a little one positive for my
measurements on the council's OS system
and from there plan submitted and they
both come up with the path being two
point two meters wide
even if we were I think I think
submitted plans and from looking else
was our system anybody else like to
comment
[Music]
okay well I'll move that we grant this
application I hear what
we're always sympathetic to the
residents but I don't think it seems
practical that the bins camp can be
empty
you missed the are the size of your
things and so on that basis I don't see
a planning reasons who refuses
application so I'll be moving grunting
if don't if anyone wants a second that
Thomas is second in that so I'll go
through everybody's name see if I can
get it right this time
so counselor dr. bara Chairman I support
the officers recommendation to grant you
councilor carry rather than to please
chairman Q comes recording regrettably I
support the officers recommendation
Thank You councillor Hartley thank you I
support the officers recommendation to
grant thank you comes with your own
grant also chair thank you come to a
Morgan I support officer recommendations
to grant chair Thank You councillor
Proctor you put yourself on one mute
Proctor to grant
Thank You councillor Rigby Thank You
councillor woo Williams Support Officer
recommendation to grant thanks Jo Thank
You councillor winst only supported
recommendations in grants Thank You
councillor Thomas support Thank You
council it's almost now be voting to
support the officers recommendation so
that application has been granted we've
run out of time everybody we've gone
over our
6:30 finish so we won't be able to cover
the rest of the items on the agenda
we're going to defer them and I think
we're going to try and work out another
date or a date for and reconvene meeting
mr. Cole is that correct and yeah if I
could defer to my colleagues and
democratic services about the
arrangements if I may okay then you need
to do that now or do we do that outside
of the meeting no I believe we need to
agree on a date for adjournment now yes
chairman just to confirm you can either
this gets to the next scheduled meeting
or a date that you think that this
meeting now you want me to come up with
the date so a consensus of amongst
members now it's not it's not permitted
all - okay - 23 sorry sorry move the
cockle I'm not hearing you properly
there could you say that again perhaps a
bit slowly yes if you can the members
going to census on a date this evening
you can come up with amongst yourself
rather than it's not the visible say
will go away and fix a date it has to be
specified tonight okay so I think we had
a possible day earlier in the week was
suggest that if we overrun this evening
that was Tuesday the 23rd of June that's
next Tuesday and um I'm working till
about could be perhaps at 5:30 on
Tuesday the 23rd just to cover those
items up with mr. tonight I suspect we
won't need much more than half an hour
to do all do those because there are no
speakers right okay so half an hour for
those lights terms with mr. night next
Tuesday how do people feel but I go
through a golfing would that be
convenient for you yes chairman that's
fine thank you that's fine
thank you dr. Barkley
[Music]
and councillor Kerry hmm what time did
you say at 5:30 yeah that'll be about
half an hour yeah that's fine thanks
thank you for that and thank you Council
accordingly
that's fine thank you
councillor Hartley aspire to me as well
thank you thank you
Thank You councillor Jerome can you hear
me get counsel that your own you'd
understand but then would of course
you're killing because you can't see me
that's fine great and councillor Morgan
yeah that's fine thanks jack thank you
thank you
[Music]
Proctor Thank You councillor Rigby Thank
You councillor Williams yeah that that's
fine with me check
thank you Thank You councillor wind
Stanley yes five major thank you
then counselor that's almost a suspect
councillor Stennis I T won't be sorted
out by that time we may call on your
services again would would you be able
to join us next Tuesday at 5:30 gamja
you can you can do that yes yeah if
required yeah yeah Thank You councillor
Thomas okay so we'll do do that next
next Tuesday the 23rd of June 5:30 and
I'll try and come early and make sure
the cameras working this time and should
only take about half an hour for the
business okay and there are our visitors
have left the meeting now mr. Colvin can
I ask and no we still have one but we
can close we can close the meeting we
can ask you in to close them to stop the
live feed if there's anything you'd like
to say to the committee yes I'm
confident